we are starting with that terrible story
from Mexico it begins with the deadly
cartel kidnapping of four Americans
Mexican authorities rescued two of the
kidnapping victims yesterday but sadly
very sadly two other companions at
zendell Brown and Shaheed Woodard are
found dead the survivors are Latavia
McGee and Eric Williams they are in
Texas Omar via francas outside the
hospital in Brownsville where they're
recovering Omar good morning to you good
morning 38-year-old Eric Williams is
recovering from surgery at this hospital
after he was shot in the leg during the
attack his wife told me when FBI agents
knocked on her door and told her what
happened she was in shock
this image shows the surviving
kidnapping victims Eric Williams and
Latavia McGee in the back of an
ambulance Tuesday
before they were returned to the U.S and
admitted to Valley Regional Medical
Center in Brownsville Texas their
terrifying abduction last Friday is seen
here a U.S law enforcement source told
CBS News investigators believe the
notorious Gulf cartel was responsible
for the attack though it's unclear why
Williams and McGee along with their
friend shaeed Woodard and zendel brown
were taken at gunpoint in Matamoros in
the state of tamolitas
Governor America Via Real said the group
was moved to multiple locations before
being found at a stash house outside the
city adding that the man who was
guarding them had been arrested to hear
his voice it was just a lot of crime we
spoke to Eric William's wife Michelle
over the phone as she described the
emotional call with her husband
confirming that he was okay what did he
tell you he's just glad to be alive it's
sad because two other people who lost
their lives one of McGee's family
members told CB news the group was
traveling from South Carolina so she
could get a cosmetic procedure and said
McGee had been to the region before for
similar reasons it's not uncommon more
than a million Americans traveled to
Mexico for health tourism last year
spending about 250 million dollars but
tamalipus is one of at least five
Mexican territories under a state
department do not travel advisory over
concerns that include crime and
kidnapping attacks on U.S citizens are
unacceptable White House Press Secretary
Kareem Jean-Pierre I would make sure
that if Americans are thinking about
traveling to Mexico that they certainly
heed the call from the state department
Mexican officials are still
investigating while U.S officials are
working to get the bodies of the other
victims back on American soil but we
don't have a timetable for when that'll
happen just yet
it is an incredibly horrific story Omar
thank you very much